SO THE WHITE HOUSE THINKS THE
DEMOCRATS OVERPLAYED THEIR HAND.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK?
THANKS A LOT.
THERE IS SO MUCH NEWS, IT'S HARD
TO KEEP UP.
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT HAPPEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THERE SENT
A WARNING TO EMPLOYERS AND SAID
DEFY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
YOU WILL FACE PUNISHMENT.
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE ILLEGAL
ALIENS THAN ANY ANOTHER STATE.
HE THREATEN ED
HE THREATEN E
HE THREATENED
HE THREATENED P
HE THREATENED PUNISHMENT
HE THREATENED PUNISHMENT T
HE THREATENED PUNISHMENT TO
CITIZENS WHO FOLLOW FEDERAL LAW.
THAT'S A THREAT TO THE BASIC
INTEGRITY OF THE UNITED STATES.
HOW BASIC?
A FAMOUS SUPREME COURT DECISION.
THE COURT HELD BECAUSE OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SUPREME TO
THE STATES IT'S UNCONSITUTIONAL
FOR THE STATES TO SABOTAGE VALID
ACTIONS OF THE FEDERAL
A LOT OF THINGS WE TAKE FOR
GRANTED REST ON THAT CASE.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
SUPREME COURT DECISIONS IN OUR
HISTORY.
IF YOU IGNORE IT, THE U.S. FALSE
APART.
LAW IT DOESN'T LIKE, WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN?
THAT MEANS TAX LAWS AND
INTER-STATE COMMERCE AND FOREIGN
TRADE, ABORTION, AND GUNS AND
YOU NAME IT.
THE COUNTRY WOULD DESCEND INTO
CHAOS.
KEEP IN MIND, EVERY STATE ALSO
MAINTAINS ITS OWN NATIONAL
GUARD.
IT HAPPENED TO US ONCE.
LIBERALS USED TO WORRY ABOUT
THINGS LIKE THIS.
THE MEDIA HYPERVENTILATED
BECAUSE A NEVADA RANCHER TRIED
TO DEFY A FEDERAL LAND USE LAW.
THEY CHEERED AS A COUNTY CLERK
IN KENTUCKY WENT TO JAIL FOR
REFUSING TO GRANT GAY MARRIAGE
LESSES.
THOSE CASES WERE NOTHING
COMPARED TO THIS.
HE ORDERED HIS SEASONS TO SECEDE
WITH HIM.
WE FOUGHT A CIVIL WAR 150 YEARS
AND THE DEMOCRATS LOST.
THEY WANT TO HELP A FOREIGN
POPULATION THAT HAS NO RIGHT TO
BE HERE.
IMMIGRANTS.
WE ASKED EVERY ONE THE SAME
QUESTION.
THE ONLY QUESTION THAT MATTERS.
EVERY NIGHT WE ASK THAT
QUESTION.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED A SINGLE
COHERRENT ANSWER.
NOT ONE.
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO REPRESENT AMERICAN
>> I REPRESENT BY CITIZENS VERY
ONE.
IN EACH SPECIFIC CASE, IF YOU
ARE AN IMMIGRANT HERE, SIMPLE,
PROVE YOU ARE PRODUCING MORE
THAN THAN YOU CONSUME?
WOULD YOU BE FOR APPLYING THAT
STANDARD?
EVERY PARENT WORRIES ABOUT THE
COST.
WHY WOULD THIS HELP THE CITIZENS
OF NEW JERSEY?
A HALF MILLION PEOPLE AND DEPORT
QUESTION BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
AN ANSWER.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THE ANSWER
IS.
HELPING AMERICANS IS NOT THE
POINT.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION MAKES THEIR
DONORS RICHER AND ENSURES THEIR
REELECTION.
IT'S DESTROYING THE COUNTRY WE
GREW UP.
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THREATENING TO PROSECUTE
CITIZENS FOR OBEYING FEDERAL
LAW.
DOESN'T THAT SOUND LIKE
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS IN THE
MEXICO AND NOT THE UNITED
STATES?
>> I THINK YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING OUR
CITIZENS AND COMMUNITY IS WELL
TAKEN.
THE REASON I INTRODUCED THE
POLICEWORK ON IMMIGRATION IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE REAL CRIME IN
OUR COMMUNITY.
DIVERTING OUR RESOURCES AWAY
FROM FIGHTING SERIOUS CRIMES TO
PARTICIPATE IN IMMIGRATION
RINGS.
>> Tucker: EMPLOYERS WHO FOLLOW
FEDERAL LAW, I AM ASKINGER WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT IMMIGRATION,
THAT'S THE BEGINNING OF CHAOS.
YOU CAN SEE THAT?
>> DEPENDING ON HOW IT'S USED IT
COULD BE.
WE HEARD SERIOUS CASES OF
EMPLOYERS HIRING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRATIONS AND THREATENING TO
TURN THEM IN AND NOT PAY THEM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S ONE REASON I
AM AGAINST ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
BECAUSE IS EXPLOITS WORKERS.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF YOUR STATE SAID.
HE SAID IF YOU FOLLOW FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW, WE WILL
PROSECUTE YOU.
I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE TO BE
CRAZY TO IMAGINE HOW OTHER
ABORTION LOUS.
-- LAWS.
THIS COULD RESULT IN A CIVIL
WAR?
>> I RESPECT YOUR CONCERNS.
THAT COULD BE ABUSED.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY CASES
CITIZENS.
IT'S A DIRECTION TO OUR OWN
TAXPAYER FUNDING LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Tucker: I GET.
IT I HAD THAT DEBATE A MILLION
TIMES.
WE COULD HAVE IT NOW.
THIS SEEMS MUCH BIGGER TO ME.
IT IS YOUR STATE.
HE IS A FELLOW DEMOCRAT WITH HIS
EYES ON THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE IS WELL KNOWN.
IT SEEMS LIKE HE STEPPED OVER A
LINE WHERE HE IS NOT BEHAVING AS
ATTORNEY GENERALS TYPICALLY DO.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY, I WORRY WHEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT STEPS OVER THE
LINE.
THAT'S WHY WE IN OAKLAND WERE SO
CONCERNED WHEN ICE AGENTS TORE
APART A FAMILY IN WEST OAKLAND
AND SENT A YOUNG MAN FOR
DEPORTATION WHO WAS NOT ACCUSED
OF ANY CRIME AND CAUSED GREAT
HARM TO OUR COMMUNITY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE THERE ARE
LOTS OF FEDERAL LAWS I DON'T
LIKE.
THEM.
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE THAT WOULD RESULT IN
CIVIL WAR.
I AM GIVING YOU AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW TO SAY TO HIM, DON'T
DO THIS.
DON'T SECEDE FROM THE REST OF
THE UNITED STATES AND DO THIS.
IT'S A CRAZY THING TO DO.
DO YOU NOT AGREE?
>> WELL, I THINK THERE IS VERY
MUCH CONCERN IN OUR COMMUNITY
ABOUT THE OVER-REACH OF ICE AND
THEIR EXPLICIT.
>> Tucker: OR COME ON.
I AM BEING RESPECTFUL.
I THINK YOU ARE A SMART PERSON.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN WHETHER A
FAMILY IN OAKLAND WAS HASSELED
BY ICE.
THIS HAS TO DO WITH THE STAYING
TOGETHER OF THE 50 UNITED
STATES.
DO YOU THINK IT'S OKAY TOMORROW
IF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF IDAHO
SAID WE WON'T RESPECT FEDERAL
GUN LAW AND WE WILL ALLOW PEOPLE
TO BUY HAND GRENADES.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FLOOD OF ILLEGAL GUNS IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> Tucker: COME ON, DON'T BE A
ROBOT.
BUMPER STICKER.
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Tucker: YOUR CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL IN THE
BIGGEST STATE IN THE UNION
SAYING I WILL PROSECUTE FOR
FOLLOWING AMERICAN LAW.
YOU DON'T THINK THAT'S HUGE?
>> I THINK THERE COULD BE A CASE
THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
I AM NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT MY
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS.
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE INTREEING
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE INTREEI G
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE INTEGEI G
I AM TALKING ABOUT THE INTEGRI G
YOU ARE IGNORING.